Thank You Betsy good morning everyone
it's a real pleasure to be here and I
bring you greetings from our president
president Levin
who would love to spend the whole week
with you actually if he could I just
heard that that he is God
since I look I report to God I thought
it was Richard Levin that I reported I'm
going to speak with you rather than give
the usual Provost's welcome instead talk
to you a little bit about the work that
my laboratory does as Betsy mentioned we
work in health communications and how to
frame messages but we also work on the
role of emotions and we take the unusual
view that emotions rather than getting
in the way of clear thinking rather than
getting in the way of behaving in the
way you want to actually help you that
we have evolved an emotional system that
is intelligent that provides information
and that actually if you pay attention
to it
can be useful and adaptive as you work
with your family in social life and
particularly in leadership so let me
talk to you just a little bit about
about this this work so we and the we is
Jack Mayer at the University of New
Hampshire and David Caruso who is here
also at Yale wrote a paper in the late
80s that was published in 1990 where we
proposed this idea that we have evolved
an emotional system that helps us think
clearly solve problems communicate deal
with social relationships deal with work
with family with friends and we call
this emotional intelligence we tried to
define it and we define it as the
ability to monitor your own feelings the
feelings of other people figure out what
they are discriminate among them and
then most importantly you
is this information to guide thinking
and action and I often talk to groups
who this is not this is an unusual idea
the idea that our emotions can help us
think and act in rational ways since so
much of the way in which emotions are
talked about in in Western and Eastern
thought is in opposition to thinking
clearly right put your emotions aside so
you can think clearly right there's
reason on the one hand and passion on
the other and I'm going to argue I don't
have much time to do it today but we
argue that that that's a mistake
that in fact our emotions give us yet
another source of information along with
logical thinking and rational thinking
that can guide our guide our behavior
alright let me give you an example of
someone who you all know who is highly
emotionally intelligent most of the time
and here he is I think you know who this
is this is a former President Clinton
also in this picture or other people who
work at Yale including me back when I
had a mustache and and my wife there in
the middle and what is going on in this
photograph is that President Clinton is
visiting Yale and he's going to give a
speech here at Yale this was after he
was no longer president it was about
five years ago and he is shaking
everyone's hand and Mike Michael who's
over here taking pictures I think he
took this picture actually that he did
and what you can see in this picture are
many emotional skills being on display
first of all he is doing something in
this picture basically what he is doing
is trying to calm me down
all right I am nervous because I'm
meeting the former President of the
United States and I look nervous in fact
my smile is only on my mouth not in my
eyes that's the first clue that that's a
fake emotion not a real emotion he on
the other hand is gripping my hand
firmly is looking me in the eye is
giving a more genuine smile but what
he's saying is what's really important I
was a Dean at the time and he's saying
Dean holiday it's so nice to see you we
already know each other
now how do we already know each other we
already know each other because about 15
minutes before this photograph was taken
I was finding a parking spot for my car
and I pulled right in front of his
limousine and parked my car and this
caused the Secret Service his guard to
jump out of the back of his limousine
and come running toward me but President
Clinton came out of the limousine he was
talking on a cell phone but he would say
it's okay it's okay he's the Dean he's
the Dean it's okay
and I didn't really realize what was
going on until I figured out that I had
cut off his car and he obviously was
looking at a book you know with
photographs of who he was going to meet
it yell and recognize me from the
photograph but now he's making it sound
like we're old friends because we've had
this interaction and he's saying that
because he is trying to make me feel
more comfortable meeting him right
he's empathizing with my nervousness and
he's trying to make a social connection
trying to make a bond now I also like
this photograph for another reason
the first reason I like this photograph
is because it demonstrates a lot of the
skills that we talk about when we talk
about people displaying emotional
intelligence that is he is reading my
feelings he's displaying his feelings
clearly he's being an empathic he's
empathizing with how
thinks I'm going to feel he's using that
empathy remember President Clinton is
the president who feels your pain right
he's very empathic guy and he's using
that to make a connection with me but
emotional intelligence isn't just one
thing I'm going to argue it's four
things in a moment but and people often
have strengths in some of these
dimensions but not always in all of them
they have a profile of strengths and
weaknesses someone might be very
empathic like Bill Clinton but might
have weaknesses in other areas now in
fact President Clinton did have a
weakness in a certain emotional area
since this is an international group I
won't spell it all out in great detail
but let's just say President Clinton's
weaknesses were in the area of impulse
control of regulating his emotions okay
regulating his own emotions he was very
good at regulating the emotions of
another person he's regulating my knees
making me feel more relaxed more calmer
but he wasn't very good at regulating
his own emotions and in fact people who
worked with him in the White House
talked about his temper he would get
angry very easily and of course the end
of his administration was characterized
by a scandal that had impulse control
and emotional management as a central
theme now the second reason I like this
photograph so much is it also provides a
clue that this is President Clinton's
weakness in the emotional intelligence
area and the clue is when you take a
look carefully at the photograph and
notice where his left hand is with
respect to my wife
we came home from this event and my wife
is named Marta and she said to me
President Clinton he is the most
charismatic person I have ever met in my
life
why can't you be more like President
Clinton that was an amazing meeting and
then when we got the photograph I see
why that she was so she was so taken
with him okay so a few years after
original paper came out we tried to
organize our thinking about emotional
intelligence in a more systematic way in
a way that would lend itself toward
doing research and we defined emotional
intelligence as having four skills the
ability to perceive or identify emotions
accurately in yourself or in other
people the ability let me skip one for a
minute the ability to understand
emotions and use language to describe
them the ability of manage emotions that
is regulate your own feelings regulate
the emotions of other people and finally
the ability to use your emotions as a
source of information as data in
problem-solving in creativity in social
situations to resolve conflict to
negotiate and to behave in the way you
would like to behave I'm going to
truncate about 20 years worth of work in
five minutes
but the short story is over time we
developed a way of actually measuring
this in people we have an assessment
tool called the mesquite and it's
organized around those four skills
perceiving I emotion using emotion
understanding emotion and managing
emotion and we give people questions
like one like this will say what is this
person fooling right now and you have to
you have to estimate what the person is
feeling that's an easy question but we
have questions with vocabulary words
with soon
where you have to figure out the best
way to manage the emotion in the
scenario we have artistic
representations where we ask what
emotion was the artist trying to convey
in this painting or photograph or
what-have-you and we can score of the
test based on what a group of emotion
researchers in thinking about the
research literature on emotion define as
the best answers now it turns out that
the these skills actually predict
leadership in the work place and I'm
only going to tell you about two very
quick studies these were small studies
that we did but this was one done with
actually students in an MBA program
where they spent 10 weeks working on a
group project and at the end of 10 weeks
they had to nominate the other people in
the group for which of their peers in
the group had the most strategic vision
who was the best communicator who was
the best the most collaborative
co-worker who was the co-worker in the
group who gave the most social support
to the other people in the group and
what we found these are sort of values
from a regression model pulled out of
the looks like it's pulled out of the
air here but the point was the person
who scored the highest on the mesquite
let me state it differently higher
scores on the mesquite predicted having
strategic vision being a better
communicator satisfying the other
members of the group and providing
social support we also did a study in an
insurance company a health insurance
company here in Connecticut now this is
a very small study it we really need to
replicate this with about 500 subjects
instead of just 40 but it gives you it
gives some clue
about the importance of emotional
intelligence we had every person in the
finance division take our test this was
44 people included the vice-president of
the company who ran the division various
financial analysts and and clerical and
administrative staff the nice thing
about this study is we measured many
things about these participants cluding
emotional intelligence and then we were
able to wait a year and a year later we
went back into the company and we could
look at their Pete their peers and
supervisors ratings of them on a kind of
360 if you've no 360 assessment of
everyone in the in this division as well
as look at their salary data who was
recommended for a raise who was promoted
over the course of the year in the
workplace and what we found these are
just correlations what we found and
again with the small sample you have to
be a little bit careful about this these
are there's a lot of errors lung noise
in these data but what I really want to
just communicate to you is the overall
trend the people who scored higher on
the mesquite were rated by their peers
as more sensitive more sociable as
contributing to a positive work
environment as being a better mood and
is having leadership potential the
people they were the people scored
higher on the whisky on the test of
emotional intelligence were rated by
their supervisors as more sociable is
more positive as contributing to a
positive work environment it's
tolerating stress better and as showing
leadership potential we also were able
to look at salary data and what we found
is if you just look down this first
column the people who scored highest on
the mesquite got the biggest salary
increases at the end of the year rose to
higher ranks in the company and their
overall salary
correlated with the ski but not
significantly so but managing emotion
the fourth branch seemed particularly
important in salary notice all of these
are two of the three here are positive
every correlation in this table is
positive suggesting that emotional
intelligence generally has an impact on
workplace performance I would love to
tell you our entire story this is just
to whet your appetite a little bit for
this idea of emotional intelligence but
if you think about emotions and you
think about the fact that we have
evolved an emotional system and you ask
yourself why have we evolved an
emotional system if it isn't useful to
us it doesn't isn't adaptive the idea if
you think about those questions the idea
of emotional intelligence doesn't sound
as radical or as strange even Darwin
who's maybe his second most famous book
was a book called
the expression of emotion in man and
animals even Darwin argued basically
that our emotional system is an
intelligent system that motivates
behaviors in animals that help them
survive and motivates behaviors in human
that help us fulfill the tasks of daily
living that isn't quite the way Darwin
would have said it but that's a 21st
century reinterpretation I'll just tell
you one thing about where we're going
with some of this work we have I am NOT
a brain scientist but the thought that I
was having there when I left I'm not a
brain scientist but I do have a brain
and I think about my brain now and then
this is the frontal lobe of the brain
and it's the part of the brain called
the frontal Pole that's involved in
solving complicated problems in
integrating information may be in social
cooperation this is all a little bit new
so so it should be a little bit
tentative in these and not over
interpreting
these kind of data but but but the idea
is when you're trying to solve a
complicated social problem this part of
the brain becomes active and this is a
slide from an fMRI study of the brain of
someone who is trying to solve a
difficult complicated social problem and
what we're looking at in this study is
well while he's solving that problem
while they are solving that problem how
much activity do we see in that part of
the brain and this graph shows the 16
people for whom we have these MRI data
and along the x-axis is their mesquite
scores their emotional intelligence
along the y axis is activity in this
frontal Pole and you see the more
emotional intelligence they have the
less hard their brain has to work to
solve the social problem in other words
they they get it very quickly the people
who have were low below average in
emotional intelligence people down here
their brain has to crank away on this
problem for a much longer period of time
they don't have their emotional
emotional system to draw up on all of
that what I just did was a real
interpretation and a kind of maybe
controversial interpretation of these
kinds of data but we believe that data
of these kind from neuroscience may bear
out the importance of emotions in
problem-solving and social behavior okay
if that interested you let me just make
one recommendation for the future for
future study and that is to go to this
first website which is a website built
by my collaborator Jack Mayer at the
University of New Hampshire wwu NHS
University New Hampshire dot edu slash
emotional and that's an underline
intelligence and at that website we have
all many of our papers and more
information about this idea
as well as some tips on how you could
use your emotions and your emotional
intelligence in the leadership roles
that you all play every day so thank you
very much for the few minutes that
you've given me and have a terrific week
thank you